Is IV vitamin C a good thing for anyone with cancer or or do or should some not do it?
What about some of the stage 4 very cancer now with a remission?
So no, I would not say vitamin IV vitamin C is good for anyone with cancer.
Nothing is good for anyone with cancer.
Well, I guess I can argue that sometimes you probably would be good.
But the negative thing about IV vitamin C is that just because you have cancer doesn't mean that you don't have something else going on.
It's just about everybody on this planet now has an autoimmune disease.
So if you also have an autoimmune disease, let's say, let's say I write Hashimoto's.
So, you know, you've been doing all these nutrients to stimulate your immune system and stuff.
Vitamin C is a very strong immune system stimulator.
Say, let's say if you didn't have cancer, then you have Hashimoto's.
And you somebody talked to you into doing IV vitamin C.
Pretty much guarantee you are going to get worse.
Your thyroid is going to get worse.
You're going to have a greater attack on your thyroid.
You're going to have a lot of tiredness issues with your thyroid.
You might go in to get a blood test and your T3 and T4 away off.
I can't figure it out.
I had it in balance for a long period of time.
Why is this kind of flaring up again?
And you're going to have issues because you're doing a really strong immune stimulation.
That's why it can be really good with cancer.
But it could be really bad with autoimmune disease.
So if you're in remission.
And let's say, let's, let's say, because I don't know your situation.
Let's say IV vitamin C helped get you there.
Maybe going down to maybe once a month to do it would be a fine thing to do.
But if you're in remission and it wasn't IV vitamin C that got you there,
I wouldn't start it.
And that would be what the matter of what kind of cancer you'd have.